et on repère marathon quatrième jour de
négociation et le plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros reste pour l'instant
sans réponse charles michel croit temps
l'accord possible et dirigeants allemand
et français gardent espoir
après une suspension se maintenant les
négociations ont repris dans
l'après-midi l'enjeu apporter une
réponse économique à l'épidémie échos
relate la vingtaine irkut est arrivé en
crimée pour visiter le chantier naval de
kertch à un déplacement qui intervient
six ans après le rattachement de la
péninsule à la russie alors que des
exercices militaires conjoints entre
l'ukraine et les pays de l'otan à sont
prévues aujourd'hui en mer fois
[Musique]
et puis situation toujours tendue au
mali la cedeao fait le forcing pour
sortir le pays de la crise quatre chefs
d'état africains sont attendus à jeudi à
bamako l'organisation ouest africaine
demande à un gouvernement d'union
nationale
aujourd'hui des militants
antigouvernementaux ont érigé des
barricades le président ibrahim boubacar
keïta est contesté depuis plusieurs
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france
c'est un bras de fer diplomatique qui se
joue depuis quatre jours à bruxelles
pour ou contre le plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros pour faire face à la
crise économique post coronavirus aller
27 mène des discussions qui s'arrête et
reprennent charles michel croit qu'un
accord possible du côté de la france ou
de l'allemagne
on garde espoir le point avec clément
hospital aînés disque est difficile pas
terminé mais difficile c'est un sommet
qui semble s'éterniser officiellement
prévu pour durer deux jours les
négociations entre les 27 dirigeants de
l'ue se poursuivre
une quatrième journée pour tenter de
trouver un accord sur un plan de relance
post coronavirus sur la table des
négociations un fonds constitué par une
capacité d'emprunt de 750 milliards
d'euros composé de 250 milliards d'euros
de prêts et surtout des dons à hauteur
de 500 milliards qui n'auront pas être
remboursés par les états bénéficiaires
le montant de ces derniers devraient
être revues à la baisse avec une
nouvelle proposition basée sur un
montant de subvention de 390 milliards
d'euros face à certaines distension
celle des pays dits frugaux l'autriche
le danemark les pays bas et la suède
tous les quatre demandent que l'aide
financière ne soit plus donné mais prêté
et avec l'obligation pour les états de
présenter leurs plans de relance
nationaux devant lieux des différents
qui fragilise l'alliance politico
économique selon le médiateur du sommet
charles michel
la question est la suivante les
vingt-sept leaders responsables devant
les peuples européens sont ils capables
de bâtir de l'unité de la confiance ou
bien à travers une déchirure
présenteront nous le visage d'une robe
faibles minées par la défiance
malgré les efforts répétés de paris et
berlin les leaders de l'ue eux peinent à
trouver un compromis
le président français semble tout de
même satisfait de l'avancée des
négociations
nous avons beaucoup avancé sur les
sujets de règles de fonctionnement de du
fonds de relance des éléments d'avancé
se sont matérialisés durant la nuit pour
essayer de trouver un accord sur le
montant total du fonds de relance et la
part de subvention comme vous le savez
est le sujet le plus sensible sans doute
des derniers jours des dernières heures
il y a un esprit de compromis qui est là
il ya eu des moments très tendu il ya
des moments des moments qui seront sans
doute encore difficile mais sur ce sujet
des choses ont avancé il faut maintenant
qu'on rentre dans le détail de ce qui
sera la nouvelle proposition
les partis sont néanmoins confiante sur
la possibilité de trouver un accord au
cours des prochaines heures
nous n'avons pas encore trouvé d'issue
cela peut encore échouer mais je suis
plus optimiste que je ne l'étais cette
nuit à un moment donné où je me suis dit
c'est fini
les négociations ne sont pas encore
terminées elles se poursuivront
prochainement mais cela fait maintenant
trois jours que nous négocions dernier
cycle de négociations qui se déroulent
maintenant dimanche a duré plus de 20
heures mais nous pouvons être très
satisfaits
nous avons réussi à réduire
considérablement le montant total
les rabais autrichien augmente très
fortement il est important que les
négociations se poursuivent à bruxelles
cela montre que tout le monde veut une
solution mais d'énormes efforts sont
nécessaires pour rendre l'europe à
nouveau solidaire le kobe 19 nous a tous
secoué la solidarité entre tous les
états portera ses fruits
ces derniers jours c'est l'avenir de
l'europe qui se joue à bruxelles ainsi
que la capacité du couple
franco-allemand à unifier une union
européenne qui ressort très affaiblie
par la crise sanitaire et ça fera
actions de jenlain la capelle député
européen du rassemblement national ils
doutent de la capacité à des manuels
macro et de bruno le maire a à négocier
bien sûr comme les négociations sont
difficiles mais je le comprends parce
que je me mets à la place des 27 pays
européens qui n'ont pas les mêmes enjeux
qui n'ont pas du tout les mêmes
objectifs qui n'ont pas les mêmes moyens
non plus et à qui on demande de
participer finalement à cette
contribution extrêmement importante ce
qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui mails
macron président la ligue française le
plus quatre jours est en train de
travailler pour ruiner la france et pour
créer un impôt supplémentaire
sera à l'échelon européen ça pose un
vrai problème et deuxième problème moi
que je pose bien sûr c'est à qui vont
aller ces subventions en france
à qui va t'il attribuer des subventions
quatre ans je vois qu'il donne 7
milliards à air france
quand je vois qu'il donne 5 milliards à
renault sans aucune contrepartie
alors qu'il y aura quatre 4500
suppressions de postes chez renault et
un et des milliers de suppressions de
postes chez air france
j'ai un vrai problème dans la capacité
mais le maquereau et de bruno le maire a
négocié impasse dans les négociations
inter europe et n sur un plan de relance
est aussi sur la relation post break
site entre européens et britanniques un
nouveau round de pourparlers aujourd'hui
à londres pour lancer une cinquième
phase dans le cadre de la transition
actuelle les négociateurs en chef des
deux parties michel barnier et david
frost doivent se retrouver ce soir pour
un dîner avant des négociations qui
s'étaleront de demain à jeudi midi au
programme le commerce des biens la pêche
l'énergie aie les transports et une
participation à certains programmes
européens une séance plénière
elles devraient ponctuer cette énième
rendez vous entre les deux parties chien
on en parle tout de suite avec claude
blanchemaison et l'expert en relations
internationales
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce soir alors à quelques mois de
la fin de la période de transition
programmée le 31 décembre prochain ce
que cette réunion c'est la réunion de la
dernière chance entre londres et
bruxelles
non ça n'est pas encore la réunion de la
dernière chance mais c'est une semaine
importante et la fin de la semaine on
l'aura tous les éléments pour apprécier
si un accord est possible d'ici deux ou
trois mois
pourquoi deux autres mois parce qu'il
faut laisser le mois de novembre et de
décembre pour les ratifications
parlementaires
on verra donc si la délégation
britannique campe sur sa position
dogmatique
les britanniques ont choisi de quitter
l'union européenne s'est fait depuis
mois de janvier ils ont ensuite décidé à
notre regret de quitter l'union
douanière et c'est ce qui sera fait le
31 décembre prochain
mais il demande un régime de libre
échange avec l'union européenne pas
n'importe quel ios ans le libre échange
comme au siècle dernier
c'est à dire sans aucune condition et y
les principaux points de divergence
entre les deux parties le premier c'est
en effet cette demande britannique de
zone de libre échange avec l'union
européenne et que l'union européenne
accueille volontiers mais à condition
naturellement que les conditions de
concurrence soit à peu près équivalente
d'un côté comme de l'autre de chanel
comme disent nos amis britanniques et
notamment les conditions sociales et les
conditions environnementales
si les otaries qui va avec nous depuis
1960 depuis 1973 et par conséquent
connaissent bien la législation
communautaire
si par hasard et leur venait à l'esprit
d'alléger les contraintes qui pèsent sur
les entreprises en matière
environnementale ou en matière sociale
évidemment cela créerait des distorsions
de concurrence et l'union européenne ne
peut pas l'accepter
le deuxième sujet c'est que
dans sa volonté de recouvrer toute sa
souveraineté par rapport à l'union
européenne les britanniques l'union
modèle la grande-bretagne n'accepte pas
que les cours européennes puissent juger
des différends commerciaux qui
pourraient apparaître dans le
fonctionnement du régime commercial par
exemple celui de libre échange qui que
les britanniques voudrait voir instaurer
troisième sujet la pêche
alors là c'est un sujet qui fâche
puisque là aussi les britanniques
veulent recouvrer leur souveraineté
intégral sur leurs zones de pêche alors
qu'actuellement ils viennent pêcher dans
les eaux des autres pays membres et les
pêcheurs les autres pays membres vient
de pêcher dans leurs eaux
il ya chèque chaque année des
négociations le complexe pour déterminer
les quotas de prises de poissons alors
les britanniques disent non nous ne
voulons plus rien avoir à faire avec
l'union européenne sur ce sujet mais
éventuellement nous pourrons négocier au
cas par cas des accords annuels
peut être avec l'union européenne peut
être avec tel ou tel état mans et puis
par ailleurs les britanniques
effectivement souhaite continuer à
participer à certains programmes
européens
il ya également des sujets très
techniques en matière de transport en
matière d'énergie qui seront discutés
cette semaine ça fait beaucoup et en
effet personnellement mais c'est
peut-être une déformation
professionnelle puisque j'ai été
diplomate
un accord n'est pas impossible sur la
sphère du libre échange on pourrait
imaginer des rendez vous réguliers où on
apprécierait de façon bilatérale union
européenne au royaume uni les conditions
de concurrence on pourra en tirer les
conséquences pour la pêche on pourrait
imaginer un dispositif du même genre
quant à aux juridictions peut tout à
fait imaginer la création d'une cour qui
serait mixte qui serait composé pour
moitié le britannique et pour moitié
deux ressortissants de l'union
européenne un accord n'est pas
totalement hors de portée
s'il ya une volonté politique de part et
d'autre et s'il ya surtout la volonté de
sortir du dogmatisme des principes pour
aller vers une négociation pragmatique
je pense qu'on le saura à la fin de la
semaine alors plus de lenche maison le
diplomate que vous êtes le regard du
diplomate en accord à quelle échéance
maintenant à à moyen terme pour les
briques site
l'accord donc va va se faire et il faut
qu'il se fasse d'ici le mois d'octobre
puis c'est encore une fois il faut
pouvoir le ratifier avant de mettre en
vigueur le 1er janvier prochain
donc en effet le temps presse le temps
presse et peut-être aussi ce qui se
passe actuellement à bruxelles sur un
autre sujet très important quel plan de
relance quatre jours de négociations
en effet si ces négociations
aboutissaient d'ici demain
je pense que ceci serait un élément
favorable pour l'autre négociations qui
n'a rien à voir mais qui est le régime
futur des relations entre le royaume uni
et l'union européenne à partir du 1er
janvier prochain
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales
entièrement restauré en mai dernier la
fresque réalisée en hommage à steve maya
calypso a de nouveau été vandalisé à des
messages haineux et des croix gammées
sont visés
la sueur en leur ok s'étend sur les murs
des deux bâtiments qui est du président
wilson sur l'île de nantes cette fresque
avait déjà été dégradée à deux reprises
en février elle avait été réalisée en
hommage au jeune homme mort noyé en loi
dans la nuit du 21 au 22 juin 2019 à
nantes après l'intervention de police
controversé c'était l'heure de la fête
de la musique on va écouter à le clergé
1 c'est une amie de steve
elle condamne bien sûr ces dégradations
ont la dgrad parce que steve est devenu
malgré lui un symbole un symbole delà de
la violence policière un soir de fête
c'est devenu aussi parce que steve
faisait partie de l'été teufeurs que
c'est une communauté qu'on juge aussi
marginale compte juste différente de
nous enfin voilà donc sur laquelle on
peut aussi s'acharner comme on comprend
pas bref c'est aussi devenu un
je pense que steve est devenu bien
malgré lui un symbole est pour moi le
style de toute façon est au-dessus
autres bien au delà de toutes ces
bassesses et ses ignominies
on l'a bien fait tension diplomatique
entre londres et hong kong
les britanniques ont suspendu leur
traité d'extradition avec l'archipel
asiatique une annonce qui intervient à
la suite d'une loi de sécurité imposées
par pékin une mesure contestée à hong
kong à le chef de la diplomatie
britannique annonce également la
poursuite de l'embargo sur les armes
potentiellement mortelle dans l'ex
colonie britannique écouter étant donné
le rôle que la chine assume désormais
pour la sécurité intérieure de hong kong
et l'autorité qu'elle exerce sur la
police le royaume uni est tendre à hong
kong l'embargo sur les armes que nous
appliquons à la chine continentale
depuis 1989
pour être clair à l'extension de cet
embargo signifie qu'il n'y aura pas
d'exportation d'armes potentiellement
mortel à de leurs composants ou de leurs
munitions du royaume uni vers hong kong
dans l'actualité également vladimir
poutine en visite en crimée aujourd'hui
le président russe participe à une
cérémonie de baptême de nouveaux navires
de guerre à cette occasion le chef du
kremlin a annoncé le report de la
procession du régime des immortels ans
en 2021 il a déclaré vouloir renforcer
les capacités d'armement de la marine on
écoute les nouveaux navires seront
équipées de systèmes d'armement de
contrôle et de communication de pointe à
longue portée ils renforceront
considérablement le potentiel de combat
de la marine ainsi que ses capacités
stratégiques
la marine a toujours défendu les
frontières de la russie de manière
fiable et aujourd'hui elle joue un rôle
extrêmement important en assurant la
sécurité de la russie
en défendant fermement les intérêts
nationaux et en contribuant à maintenir
l'équilibré stratégique et la stabilité
dans le monde et cabinet civil et leurs
veuves fait baptême la dmr poutine après
le temps de visiter le chantier naval de
kertch avant de s'entretenir notamment
avec les responsables à de la
construction à l'occasion de ce
déplacement
retour en images sur le rattachement de
la crimée à la russie c'était en 2014
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hu
[Musique]
et pour thierry mariani député européen
du rassemblement national des murs
poutine rappelle aux occidentaux que le
rattachement de la crimée à la russie a
n'est pas négociable
les tensions sont à la fois avec états
unis et et craignent mais aussi de
l'oublions pas à la fois avec la turquie
la turquie est sur le flanc sud et pour
la russie ces manoeuvres sans qu'elle
ait elle aussi décidé d'organiser sont
aussi l'occasion de montrer d'abord
qu'elle est prête en toutes
circonstances et deuxièmement la visite
de poutine en crimée montre que c'est un
sujet j'allais dire non négociable vous
savez qu'on a eu une sorte de référendum
en consultation une consultation
organisée auprès du peuple russe
il ya une dizaine de jours et dans les
articles de la modification du
référendum qui étaient proposées il y
avait justement le fait que toute
cession de territoires soient non
négociable qui voulait dire en clair que
là la crimée le message est très clair
pour les occidentaux
en 2014 ce qui s'est passé est
définitive
mais dans l'actualité internationale et
également la situation en roumanie
toujours l'impasse politique jeudi
quatre présidents ouest africains sont
attendus à bamako objectif trouver une
issue à la crise sociopolitique que
traverse le pays à la communauté
économique des états d'afrique de
l'ouest prônent un gouvernement d'union
l'opposition ait dit non elle mène
depuis plusieurs mois la contestation
contre le président ibrahim boubacar
keïta et des tensions encore dans la
capitale aujourd'hui demi-douzaine de
barricades ont été érigées
les dernières législatives ont mis le
feu aux poudres la corruption
d'insécurité la disparition l'opposant
soumaila cissé aussi je vous propose
d'écouter le président de la mission de
la cedeao fond il est nécessaire de
mettre en place de toute urgence un
gouvernement d'union nationale si la
base du consensus et tenant compte des
recommandations du dialogue national
inclusif et des propositions de
répartition suivante 50% proviendront de
la coalition pour pouvoir tendre %
proviendront de l'opposition et 20% de
la société civile
aucune forme de changement non
constitutionnels d'accession au pouvoir
ne sera acceptée par la cedeao
je me repose maintenant dans l'analyse
de balson bouyer 6 et les porte parole
du conseil supérieur à de la diaspora
malienne
placido prétend peluche
anticonstitutionnelle ce qu'on propose
on les brûle comme recoller les
propositions de la cedeao
elle met foule du pied la constitution
malienne or la démission du président
malien et bien et bien un tri de la
condition du magny donc aujourd'hui
c'est ceux qui radicalisent un peu plus
les positions du mouvement du 5 mai 5
juillet si celle ci étant dit je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la cedeao doit continuer
sa mission de bons offices pour aller
vers l'apaisement et entendre c'est de
cette frange de la population qui est
d'ailleurs la majorité passé quand elle
propose 50% d'une futur gouvernement
d'union nationale qui proviendraient du
boundou goût du pouvoir et une 30% de
l'opposition et 20% de la société civile
c'est de ne pas tenir compte des
réalités du pays actuellement et du
contexte actuel est le reste de
l'actualité internationale en bref un et
en images aux etats unis les tensions se
poursuivent à portland dans l'orégon ou
des agents fédéraux ont été envoyés pour
mettre un terme aux manifestations
organisées devant lé tribunal de la
ville afin de protester contre les
brutalités policières et le racisme à
systémique les rassemblements émaillées
d'échauffourées avec les forces de
l'ordre sont régulièrement dispersées à
coups de gaz lacrymogène est la colère a
redoublé après une série d'arrestations
de protestataires sans motif apparent
des dizaines de blessés ira à bagdad et
dans plusieurs autres villes d'irak
comme un hilla au sud de la capitale des
heurts entre les forces de l'ordre et
des manifestants opposés au gouvernement
qui dénonce notamment la gestion de la
crise du coronavirus par le pouvoir
l'irak qui compte près de 3800 décès
liés aux côtés de 19 et puis à
johannesburg de nombreuses tombes ont
été creusées dans un cimetière de la
ville alors que l'afrique du sud le pays
le plus touché par la pandémie sur le
continent a franchi le seuil des 5000
morts le pic de l'épidémie est attendu
pour les prochaines semaines les
autorités sud africaines avait imposé à
fin mars un confinement extrêmement
strictes à mais les mesures ont été
progressivement assouplies pour éviter
un effondrement de l'économie
on reparle du coronavirus mais à
l'échelle internationale au total le
vide a tué six cent mille personnes dans
le monde dont 40 mille décès au mexique
80000 au brésil au venezuela des
médecins cubains effectué depuis
plusieurs jours des recherches à
maracaibo pour identifier les cas de que
vides depuis le début de la pandémie le
savoir-faire sanitaire de la havane
s'exporte les détails avec lundi qu avec
des compétences mondialement reconnue
l'exportation du savoir faire sanitaire
est l'une des ressources premières de
cuba où l'on dénombre pas moins de 34
universités de médecine depuis le début
de la crise de coronavirus plusieurs
pays ont donc eu recours aux services
proposés par la havane vendredi dans le
nord-est du venezuela
des médecins de l'île ont effectué des
contrôles dans la ville de maracaibo
pour identifier des personnes présentant
des symptômes du coronavirus des
désinfections de rue dans la capitale de
l'état de zulia ont également eu lieu
maracaibo est la ville la plus touchée
du venezuela par le cos vite 19
cette concentration de cas a provoqué
l'effondrement du système de santé local
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans cette
commune et nous faisons une visite
maison par maison pour mener une enquête
sur les passions de kobe 19 dans le but
de détecter que certains d'entre eux
présentent des symptômes liés à la
maladie de qu'ovide c'est une grande
importance car c'est la seule façon
d'isoler les patients et d'éviter la
contagion dans la communauté
déjà en mars dernier 52 médecins et
infirmières accueilli en héros avaient
été dépêchés en italie une équipe aux
compétences reconnues qui comptait des
membres avec une expérience de crise
sanitaire certains ayant combattu le
virus ebola en afrique
nous apprécions que de nombreuses
personnes nous considère comme des héros
mais je pense que nous sommes simplement
des médecins mais aujourd'hui nous
jouons juste notre rôle pour combattre
la pandémie
nous luttons contre une pandémie et
c'est à nous d'agir de la meilleure
façon possible dans cette situation au
moins d'avril l'afrique du sud avait à
son tour accueilli
plus de 200 médecins et soignants pour
lutter contre le coronavirus une
délégation accueillie par plusieurs
ministres et dont la présence avait
réjoui le président sud africain
cyril ramaphosa mon moral est remonté
hier soir lorsque j'ai appris que 219
soignants cubain avait débarqué dans
notre pays
cela fait suite à la demande que j'ai
faite au président cubain lorsque le
coronavirus commencé à se manifester
dans notre pays
j'ai donc demandé au gouvernement cubain
de nous envoyer des spécialistes spécial
s c'est la continuité de la merveilleuse
relation que le président mandela avait
forgé avec fidel castro nous bénéficions
donc des grands progrès que nelson
mandela accompli pour notre pays depuis
fin juin c'était une première pour la
france
quinze médecins cubains ont été
accueillis en martinique pour pallier la
pénurie de médecins faso covic 19 au
même moment c'est en guinée-bissau
qu'une autre brigade médicale cubaine et
est accueilli pour les mêmes raisons au
total ce sont pas moins de trente mille
médecins cubains qui sont déployés à
l'année dans une soixantaine de pays où
il aide à compléter le maillage
sanitaire cuba qui a envoyé de nombreux
médecins à travers le monde pendant
cette période de pandémie un sujet
abordé par pierre pissavy yvernault dans
la grande interview avec catherine
conconne elle fait matrice de la
martinique a retrouvé sur arte france
demain à 18h30 extraits
cuba son régime c'est vrai qu'il est
décriée c'est vrai qu'il est pointé du
doigt on parle beaucoup de droits de
l'homme qui sont bafouées excité a
certainement mais j'en veux dire aussi
que cuba aussi ses bons côtés
cuba aussi un peuple qui est aujourd'hui
éduqué dans le bon sens du terme
cuba n'a pas lésiné sur les moyens les
filles à l'éducation à la santé
il faut également mettre sans valeur et
puis est ce que cuba aussi ne se durcit
fie pas à cause de la situation
internationale qui lui fait pas de
cadeau
soyons quand même clé
lorsqu'on voit vous a demandé des
sanctions américaines j'imagine des
sanctions américaines qui sont prises
dans l'impunité moi je comptais déposer
une question au gouvernement mais je
vais le faire à la rentrée puisque notre
scission arrive à sa fin pour demander à
l'état français
quelle est la réaction par rapport à ce
que subit cuba aujourd'hui le veto dont
disposent les états unis à l'onu à l'onu
l'eau permet de faire n'importe quoi
le permet de faire ce qu'ils veulent et
aujourd'hui mon peuple frais en cubes et
subit de plein fouet cet embargo qui
frappe cette île cette île soeur de
choses qui sont inacceptables qui sont
pour moi inacceptable
on veut réduire cuba m cuba à genoux
réduit au cuba de nous pour sa
nourriture pour ces médicaments est ce
que vous vous rendez compte
qu'aujourd'hui mois caribéenne je n'ai
plus la cuba cubana qui me permettrait
d'aller à cuba travailler avec les
cubains aller en vacances à cuba
rencontrer mais mais mais mais frire
cubain parce que les états unis étaient
à dix à la compagnie nationale de loin
des avions on leur interdisait déjà
d'acheter aujourd'hui leur interdit de
louer pour aller à cuba je suis obligé
aujourd'hui de quitter la matinée dallas
paris ensuite de paris de retourner à
laval
je vous laisse imaginer les eyzies et le
bocal dans lequel on affirme cuba comme
ceux d'autrui je pense qu'il est temps
de réagir à ces mesures qui sont à mon
avis hein juste une grande interview à
retrouver demain c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de votre attention va se
retrouver en directeur dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous sur un ferry
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous répondez à tous ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui que l'effort
militaire ne correspond plus à nos
besoins
les crises géostratégique c'est comme
les crises sanitaires c